something very different from our
intuition that we have from things like
engineering which says it's hard to get
complicated things actually in the
computational universe it's very easy to
get complicated things one important
feature of those complicated things is
this question about how time works and
the question is if you want to know what
is this thing going to do after a
billion steps how do you figure that out
well you might say well I'm you know I'm
going to use all kinds of fancy math and
all kinds of things like this and I'm
going to be able to figure out what does
this do after a billion steps I don't
actually have to run those billion steps
I'm going to I'm going to jump ahead and
figure out what it's going to do
it turns out that's not possible which
is a thing that you would think from you
know you'd say well we do science
science is about predicting things we we
you know we go further with science
we'll be able to predict it we'll we'll
get it eventually turns out that's not
the case and we've kind of known that
that's not the case in one way or
another for about 100 years now ever
since people started to understand the
notion of universal computation let me
explain how that how that works so so
one of the questions is when you see a
system like this you can ask kind of you
can think of what it's doing as a
computation it starts off with some
input it goes crunch crunch crunch it
generates some output question is sort
of how sophisticated is that computation
and in in the past before people maybe
you know 100 years ago people would have
said okay you want to make a an adding
machine you go buy the adding machine
from the adding machine store you and
multiplying machine's a different
machine then it was realized first in
the 1920s but then more clearly in the
1930s that no you could actually have a
universal machine where you have one
fixed piece of hardware and you just
feed it different programs to make it do
different things wasn't obvious how
Universal that was so to speak that term
that it was possible to to do sort of at
the time it was thought to be sort of
any reasonable computation you could do
with let's say a turing machine that was
fed different programs
so the question is uh once once you have
this idea of universal computation you
you know that you you're going to have
some okay so back back to thinking about
different kinds of systems that do
computations and one question you might
ask is sort of how do these systems
compare is one of them kind of
computationally more sophisticated than
another or what and the thing that is
sort of a summary of lots of things that
I've kind of studied in the
computational universe is a thing I call
the principle of computational
equivalence which basically says that
when you look out in the computational
universe of all possible programs that
as soon as you see programs whose
behavior is not obviously simple it's
not just repetitive nested some some
very obvious regularity as soon as you
see behavior that is not obviously
simple most of the time the computations
that will be going on in that system
will be as sophisticated as the
computations that can happen in any
system
okay so what does that so this is by
principle of computational equivalence
what does it mean well what what is it
what what its consequences what has many
consequences but one of it's one of its
interesting consequences is a phenomenon
I call computationally reducibility
which um uh which is the following thing
so imagine that you are a predictor of
one of these systems and you are doing a
computation in your brain whatever else
and um uh okay so
if you want you don't have to
I was hoping to talk about some very
different kinds of things even different
things than I've ever talked about
before here but we're we're still in the
in the initial run-up here
um because I need to explain to you some
some basic concepts before we get get
too deep into other things all right so
principle of computational equivalence
idea is you're trying to predict what
the system is going to do you as a
predictor are doing computational things
the system is doing computational things
normally you expect you will be able to
be sort of smarter than the system
itself and even though it might take the
system a billion steps to figure out
what it does after a billion steps you
will be able to just work out some
mathematical formula or something and be
able to jump to the end and say this is
what it's going to do it's the typical
experience and kind of the mathematical
equations approach to science that you
have you're dealing with computational
reducibility in order to find out where
sort of an idealized Earth is going
around an idealized Sun you don't have
to follow you know a million orbits to
know where it's going to be a million
years from now you just have to plug a
number into a formula and get the
results but if these systems are
computationally equivalent if the
predictor and the system being predicted
are computationally equivalent in their
sophistic in their computational
sophistication you won't be able to do
that kind of jumping ahead so you'll be
stuck having to go through and say step
by step what does the system do and
that's you you have to do sort of as
much computation as the system itself
does so in a sense that saying from
within science you were learning that
science has a certain fundamental
limitation it's not able to say what's
going to happen at the end without just
essentially running it and seeing what
happens now you might say that's a
terrible thing that's a limitation of
science it's a good thing for for the
existence of of like us humans because
if you think about you know the what's
the what are we achieving in life we
could say well you know people could say
well you don't need to live out your
lives we just know the answer in the end
is 42. we can just jump to the end and
see what the answer is you just watched
a clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy